The first trailer for Thor: Ragnarok has dropped,
and for less than two minutes of footage,
it’s positively loaded with intel on Marvel’s
latest project.
From how the Incredible Hulk fits into all
this, to the new big bad who looks to take
out all of Asgard on her own, here’s everything
we learned in the first Thor: Ragnarok trailer
— and why we think the film will almost
certainly blow us all away when it drops on
November 3rd.
Hela is hella powerful
Outside of Loki, villains have almost always
been the weak point across the MCU.
After the fairly boring Dark Elves in The
Dark World, Marvel is looking to up the ante
in a big way with the villain in Ragnarok.
Cate Blanchett is playing Marvel's Norse goddess
Hela — and she more than lives up to the
title.
We get our first look at Hela here, and she
is positively terrifying.
Blanchett looks plenty intimidating in the
role, as Thor and the full might of Asgard
looks to be no match for her destructive capabilities.
Mjolnir destroyed
Thor’s weapon of choice has been a key piece
of the MCU since we first got a peek at Coulson
and his S.H.I.E.L.D. team trying to mine it
out of the ground in Iron Man 2’s post-credit
scene.
But, all of that ends here.
Thor tries to take on Hela with a trademark
throw of Mjolnir.
But, she’s powerful enough to stop it midair.
Worse?
She also crushes it into charred little hammer
bits, meaning Thor is officially hammer-less.
No more hammer time, y’all.
"Stop.
Hammer time!"
Considering the big deal that’s been made
about this hammer, and how no one can lift
it...
Or in this case, hold it, without being worthy,
it makes one wonder just how powerful Hela
might actually be.
That hammer has always been one of the most
powerful objects in the MCU, and it was just
turned into a scrap heap.
“Asgard is dead”
We see Hela face off with the whole of Asgard’s
army on her own, shortly before fire engulfs
the entire city.
Hela makes the point even clearer with her
line:
“Asgard is dead.”
We’ve seen Asgard face its fair share of
damage in other Thor films, but we’ve never
seen the city of the gods actually wiped out.
The events here could have a lasting impact
on the MCU, especially if it means there are
a lot of displaced Norse gods just roaming
the galaxy.
The new faces
From Robert Redford in Captain America: The
Winter Solider, to Glenn Close in Guardians
of the Galaxy, the MCU has been attracting
its fair share of A-list actors over the past
few years.
Now, it’s time for Jurassic Park alum Jeff
Goldblum to make the jump into the Marvel
universe.
Here, Goldblum plays the Grandmaster, who
seems to be pulling the strings of the super-powered
gladiatorial games where Thor finds himself
after being captured.
Goldblum looks amazing in his costume, and
this looks to be one of the most colorful
Marvel films to date.
The footage here also gives us our first good look at Creed alum Tessa Thompson, an Asgardian warrior who seems to be working for the Grandmaster.
Valkyrie will serve as a potential love interest
for Thor, with Natalie Portman’s Jane Foster
off the board.
Judging by what we see of her here, it’ll
be interesting to see how her allegiances
are tested along the way.
And finally, Karl Urban takes on the role
of Skurge, the Executioner, in one of the
coolest shoutouts to Thor's comic book past
that we've seen on screen.
When you see this...the filmmakers are reminding
you of The Mighty Thor #362.
In that issue, which comes from the legendary
story arc by Walt Simonson in the '80s, the
Executioner holds off the hordes of Hel...with
a couple of machine guns and his pure, unfiltered
rage.
Karl Urban's already a comics-to-film legend
for his role in Dredd.
Chances seem good he'll go down in history
for doing the Executioner justice, too.
Loki's back
When last we left Loki, he was the secret
king of Asgard, having assumed Odin’s form
at the end of The Dark World.
But, we see him back in his Tom Hiddleston
face here, wielding a few knives during a
fight scene.
Loki shows up a bit later sitting with the
Grandmaster and watching Thor’s fight with the Hulk.
So, is Loki pulling the strings to keep Thor
locked up?
Is he there to rescue him?
Is he just there to enjoy the show?
We can’t wait to find out.
Heimdall goes rogue
Idris Elba’s Heimdall has been a quiet force
in all the Thor movies, guarding the Bifrost
and generally being a legit badass.
But, he loses the fancy armor and finds himself
flying solo in Ragnarok.
The brief shot of Heimdall we see here shows
him looking very much like scruffy Idris Elba,
but he’s still wielding that sword and mowing
down bad guys as needed.
We’ve never really seem Heimdall out on
his own, seemingly without a Bifrost to defend.
Will he eventually join up with Thor to try
and retake Asgard?
Thor and Hulk reunited
As expected, the best moment is when we finally
get a look at Mark Ruffalo’s Hulk in full-on
World War Hulk attire, ready to take on all
comers in the gladiator ring.
“Yess!"
Yeah, we felt the same way, Thor.
We still don’t know exactly how Hulk ended
up in deep space, or why he seems keen
to start wailing on Thor, but this is the
first set-up of the weirdest buddy movie we
never knew we wanted to see.
They borrowed Star-Lord’s walkman
Guardians of the Galaxy set the tone for the
MCU in regards to how popular music can be
used to sell a story, and it seems Thor: Ragnarok
borrowed a cassette or two from Star-Lord’s
tape deck.
The entire trailer is set to the rocking beats
of Led Zeppelin’s “Immigrant Song,”
and combined with the neon colors and font
book straight out of Star Trek II: The Wrath
of Khan, it sets a tone unlike any Thor movie
we’ve seen before.
And it looks like the most fun they’ve had
in Asgard in ages.
Well, you know, except for all the destruction
and stuff.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!